avec 800 mille entrées annuelles ce
multiplex est d'ordinaire l'armageddon
des salles obscures dijonnaise un
véritable aimant à spectateurs mais
depuis sa réouverture le 22 juin
ce cinéma vit un mauvais scénario la
fréquentation est faible
95 entrer ce jour là aux séances de 16
heures pour les rares spectateurs
présents c'est l'aubaine
ils peuvent renouer avec le septième art
sans craindre de croiser la foule des
grands jours
ça fait déjà longtemps couvé par les
enseignements et bas les enfants avaient
envie de retourner voir mais sympa c'est
plaisir de sortir toutes les deux une
désaffection qui s'expliquerait en
grande partie par la frilosité des
distributeurs
les studios américains ne cessent de
repousser les dates de sortie et des
blockbusters de l'été car aux états unis
les cinémas sont toujours fermés
conséquence en france
les exploitants prix pour étoffer
rapidement leur programmation
on attend effectivement les gros films
porteurs tels que christopher nolan tels
que mullan qui avait été annoncé le 22
juillet qui ont été reportés le 31
juillet et qui sont maintenant date est
plutôt le goujat 19 août
mêmes causes mêmes effets dans sept
salles art et essai de dijon là encore
l'affiché maigrelette du côté du cinéma
d'auteur résultat 700 à 800 entrées par
semaine
c'est moitié moins qu'un était normal
toute la filière est inquiète mais nous
aussi particulièrement puisque on est
beaucoup plus fragiles économiquement
que que les multiplexes qui sont adossés
à
système financier beaucoup plus large
que le nôtre évidemment donc en capacité
à résister on n'a pas donc nous on a
besoin des spectateurs assez vite square
crise ponctuelle ou changement profond
des habitudes
netflix a vu son nombre d'abonnés
explosé pendant le confinement de quoi
inquiéter un peu plus les gérants de
cinémas déjà dans la tourmente